well we often see images of deadly
crashes on our roads just like the
tragedy that unfolded in north las vegas
but we rarely see the emotional toll on
victims families years later especially
on children left behind it is a story 8
news now has been following in the
i-teams vanessa murphy has this
exclusive story from a perspective we
don't often hear about a child left
behind because of the crime
kayden mcginnis was two years old when
he was in this car with his mother and
two of her friends on halloween night in
2013. drunk driver leonard walker caused
this crash kaiden's mother savannah who
was just 17 was killed do you remember
her or
no
kaden is now 10 years old his
grandmother julie mcginnis was raising
him after the crash but in 2018 she
passed away from cancer he said love you
mama now kayden lives with his aunt
uncle and their six children i don't
even know who i am anymore
and i try to stay strong for my kids and
for him the most brianna cerrados admits
she is struggling after the loss of her
sister and her mother and she feels
justice hasn't been served it kills me
to know that i caused this through a
deal walker pleaded guilty to a felony
charge of driving under the influence
and causing death he received a sentence
of seven to 20 years this is the little
boy that will never see his mother again
in december of 2019 he was released on
residential confinement think house
arrest brianna says there wasn't much of
an effort to notify her then in august
of 2020 walker asked for parole i would
never do it again the 8 news now i-team
requested video of the hearing from the
parole board we were told there were
technical difficulties and we were
provided video with poor quality
i'm still trying to live with what i did
and decision i made
and to the victims i'm still i'm very
sorry
and i i really really hope you can
forgive me so i can really start to
forgive myself walker's girlfriend made
a plea too every day our daughter asks
if he can take her to the park
and i just ask for your consideration in
granting his pearl so we can finally
give our daughter what she's been asking
for and then i can't say that i forgive
him and i'm probably the most forgiving
person ever rihanna's turn and my mom
said that when she got the phone call at
9 19 p.m
with the news about my sister she died
at 9 19 p.m
and as i sat down riding this last night
i realized a big part of me died too she
asked for walker to serve the remainder
of his sentence behind bars to go 85
miles an hour i want you guys to
understand my sister was internally
decapitated
and they found her with her arms thrown
over my nephew
the only one not hurt because
and all i could think
every day is what were her last words
how scared was she how scared was he
i play these images in my head and it
doesn't go away kayden was at that
hearing the dude who killed my mom
he was like right there it's been really
hard for me
i don't even know what it's like to even
have a mom the next month the family
received this letter leonard walker was
granted parole
the 29 year old sentence is set to
finish completely this june according to
the department of corrections what i
would like is him to serve a life
sentence like we're serving she says
holidays especially halloween are a
painful time for their family kaden
didn't speak for more than a year after
the crash due to ptsd
and now he sits trying to explain what
happened to his mom to other kids at
school is a challenge
because people ask about it i tell them
about it they don't believe anything
vanessa murphy everything he knows has
been taken live local now